if there's
one thing that we saw hit the boiling
point
uh in 2020 into
2021 is the role that technology plays
in surveilling us you know
elon musk comes out and you know he says
run to signal and of course the day
traders run to some other
stock and run it up from 60 cents to six
bucks a share
but how how
do we live in america and
have a company like facebook say
the up the ability to opt out is going
away
on february the 8th prepare yourself i
mean how in the world does that work
one of your predictions for 2021 is that
this situation is hitting
a break point explain that yeah
so look danielle i think in fact i
highly recommend
this book uh by shashana zubov who was
the first
uh tenured business school professor at
the harvard business school first female
uh
tenured business school professor
shoshana zubov wrote a book called
the age of surveillance capitalism and
i have to tell you it is both
ridiculously insightful
and so deeply disturbing uh at the same
time
and it is in fact these big tech
companies
that have decided to hoover up all the
data that exists and connect it
so that their ultimate objective is to
manage
us uh to to extract away effectively
your autonomy
so that you may think that you're doing
things for your own doing but
they may in fact be guiding you like
they're
like a mouse proverbially through the
maze to the cheese so to say
so what do i mean by that well turns out
google
will be reading your email on a device
and all the other things
that you use for gmail uh so that's fine
maybe google can read your email maybe
you say i have nothing to hide
uh they have your fitbit so they know by
the way your
heart rate is moving at a certain rate
when you're reading that email because
they have time stamps on this stuff
and then by the way they know you walked
into your house and the first thing you
did
was x because the nest device that they
own
is there and checks the monitors the
temperature and movement in that room
and so they know your pattern of
movement etc
now they also know that you checked your
email
that came from this person on an android
device there's two billion of those so
they have a data of where you are for
most of the time
they know not just because most android
devices have not just location
they have barometric pressure gauges
they can tell not just that you're at
the starbucks on the corner of 14th
and and third that you're on the 13th
floor of that building and there's a
family law
office up there so it's hey you were
communicating with people that you're
not married to you were at the starbucks
with that other person
then you went up to the family law
office they now surmise that there's a
high probability you're considering a
divorce
here's your ad but do it yourself
divorce kit um
it's just a little too look i will here
in fact this is great evidence right
here on the video
i've moved to a dumb phone because i
don't like the monitoring and by the way
we haven't even gotten into the
the metadata problem right so it's not
just
for instance that you use your phone to
tweet
it's that each tweet is tagged with i
don't know what the number is
50 70 pieces of metadata where were you
before what did you look at before what
was the email you read before what did
you do after which ip address was it
which app were you on before
uh what what you've been reading
thinking about etc beforehand
you know all of these things come into
play with each and every thing
and then they use big data and analytics
to say all right this
implies this about your behavior you're
thinking it what have you
so i think i think there's a there's a
reasonable call
to suggest we should restore our
autonomy by pushing back against this
and i agree with you it becomes
hard for individuals to do so which
means it is a reasonable ground for
regulatory intervention
because uh you know there's no other way
to
contain that perhaps well you know
i'm no big advocate for big government
but at some point
company becomes bigger than the
government that's right and and that
that's problematic
[Music]
you